Hôm nay, hàng thằng sau năm 2018, tôn tin từ công an tỉnh Đồng Ngài đơn vị đã bắt sửa thành công
với mình phúc, sinh nămu nghìn trị trăm chỉ mới làm, quế ở tỉnh phụ cần thơ, hiện đang tạm chú tại
Up High, xa lòng thọ, huyện nhân trạch tỉnh Đồng Ngài, là đối tượng sức hại nữ chủ tipped tạm
hóa cứ tài xàn. Chứ đó, lúc 15 giờ 3 mi từ phút của ông qua, tại tịp tạm hóa tình hại ở
ở ấc đất mới, xa lòng phút, huyện lòng thành đã sửa 1 vụ rất nổi, cứ tài xàn. Nát nhân là
bà lưu thị thu xe, sinh năm 2017, chủ tipped tạm hóa tình hại đã bị đối tượng dùng vụ khi khu xe khu tài xàn,
sau đó xa hại nạn nhân. Sau khi về ảnh, đối tượng đã nhìn trong tổ thóa về hướng và dự vũ tạo.
Ngài xóa khi giận được tìm báo, đồng xí thiệu tướng với nước hại, giám đốc công an tỉnh với hiện chương trí đạo các lực lượng công an tỉnh Đồng Ngài tập trú trí sếp,
chứ bắt đối tượng về ảnh. Chỉ sơ hơn 5 giờ trí sếp nhành, á dụt đồng bộ các bị pháp nhi bụt,
công an tỉnh Đồng Ngài phối hợp với công an tỉnh Phố Chí Minh đã bắt được với mình phố.
Hí í đang lần chốn tại đi bàn phương cộng lãnh, quận một thịp Phố Chí Minh.
Hịt công an Đồng Ngài đang tích tục đưa cha, sử lý đối tượng theo viên của pháp lật.